قد يختفي فجاه وبيانات المستخدمين قد
تتعرض لخطر السرقه او الانتشار تحذير
اطلقه هنا خبراء تقنيون بعد تسريب اجزاء
من كود مصدر موقع تويتر عبر الانترنت وهو
رمز الكمبيوتر الاساسي الذي تعمل عليه
الشبكه الاجتماعيه الزرقاء المشهوره طبعا
وهنا يعد ذلك اختراقا نادرا وكبيرا
للملكيه الفكريه للموقع في الوقت الذي
تحاول فيه الشركه تقليل المشكلات الفنيه
وحفظ على علامه التجاريه في ظل قياده
ملكها ايلون ماسك وتحرك موقع تويتر هنا
لازاله الرمز المسرب عن طريق ارسال اشعار
انتهاك حقوق النشر
لقطها وهي منصه تعاون عبر الانترنت لمطوري
البرنامج حيث تم نشر الرمز عليها وفقا
لنيورك تايمز وامتثلت جيت هاب وازاله
الرمز طبعا في اليوم نفسه لكن نيويورك
تايمز بانه لم يتضح كم من الوقت ظل هذا
الرمز مسرب على الانترنت لكنه يبدو انه
كان متاحا للعامه لعده اشهر على الاقل
تويتر طلبت ايضا من المحكمه الامريكيه في
كاليفورنيا ان تامر بتحديد الشخص الذي
شارك الرمز واي افراد اخرين قاموا بتنزيله
وهنا نقلت نيويورك تايمز ايضا عن مطلعين
على تحقيق الداخليه قولهم ان تويتر بدات
تحقيقا في التسريب
وتوقع المدراء التنفيذيون الذين يتعاملون
مع الامر ان المتهم المسؤول عن ذلك غادرت
تويتر عام 2022
[موسيقى]